>>Female Presenter: Hi everyone. Has anyone
ever fumbled with using a semi-colon or question
mark? Struggled with whether it was more appropriate
to use 'who' or 'whom'? Further or farther?
Authors@Google is happy to welcome grammar
guru Mignon Fogarty. Mignon is the host of
'Grammar Girl' and founder of Quick and Dirty
Tips. 'Grammar Girl' shares quick and friendly
tips to improve your writing, including tips
on punctuation, style, business tips and more.
Before 'Grammar Girl', Mignon has worked as
a magazine and technical writer. She has a
BA in English from the University of Washington
and an MS in Biology from Stanford University.
With that said, let's welcome Mignon.
[applause]
>>Mignon Fogarty: Thank you, Nadine. [applause]
Thank you. Thank you so much for having me
here today. I, I used to live in the Bay Area
and it's, it's great to be back. Great to
be at Google. Google does not disappoint.
I'll tell you. Even your parking lot is cool.
[laughs]
[audience laughter]
So let's get started. We're running a little
late. So who am I? I am known on line as 'Grammar
Girl' and so far, I have three new books out.
They came out a week or two ago so now I have
six books about writing. The 'Hundred and
One Word' Series is new so '101 Misused Words
You'll Never Confuse Again'. And we'll talk
about some of those today. '101 Words Every
College Graduate Should Know'. We actually
won't talk about those today. My 'Ultimate
Writing Guide for Students' is the most comprehensive
book available from the Grammar Girl's stable
of books. And then my first book was a New
York Times Bestseller. 'The Grammar Devotional'
is my personal favorite and the poorest selling
of all my books. [laughs] It's like a tip
a day calendar in book form. I adore it. It's,
it's wonderful. It's not that popular. [laughs]
[audience laughter]
And then the first book I did is, actually
not even sure it counts. It's a one hour audio
book so is it a book? Is it not a book? I
don't know but the reason my first book was
a one hour audio book was because I actually,
whoops. I actually got my start podcasting.
So I was a science writer in the Bay Area
and I was producing a science podcast and
at the same time I was a technical writer
and editor and I found that the work I was
editing from people, people were making the
same mistakes over and over again. And I'd
fix them and sometimes they'd send them back
to me changed back to the wrong way. [audience
chuckles] And I was getting really frustrated
and I, and I was already podcasting and I
thought, 'Well, I could give people a five
minute quick tip podcast with writing tips.
Nobody wants a one hour long lesson about
grammar.' Of course you're all here today
so you prove me wrong. [laughs]
[audience laughter]
But at the time, I thought nobody wanted an
hour long lesson about grammar. So five minute,
fun friendly tips. Maybe, maybe someone will
listen. Maybe ten people I can help. And I
produced, since I was already doing the science
podcast, I had all the equipment. So I made
Grammar Girl and it was literally in a coffee
shop in Santa Cruz. Jotted ideas down on a
napkin and had the podcast up in three days.
And it went to the iTunes Top 100 within three
or four weeks just based on word of mouth.
And it's been there ever since. That was about
five years ago. I'm now almost up to 300 Grammar
Girl podcasts and because Grammar Girl was
so successful and I had been in Silicon Valley
working at Startups, I knew I was onto something.
So then I founded the Quick and Dirty Tips
Podcast Network which now has 14 or 15 shows.
You know we've got 'Money' and 'Public Speaking'
which I should listen to more [chuckles] and
'Productivity' and 'Investing' and all sorts
of topics. And I'm partnered with McMillan
Publishing, my publisher on the Quick and
Dirty Tips Network. So that's who I am. That's
maybe why you should care.
And I'm so excited to be here because Google
is enormously helpful in my work and people
ask me questions about Google so in my e-mail
newsletter, I have covered 'Is Google a verb?
And if you use it as such, should you capitalize
it?' And people in the language world, I don't
know if you know, but in the linguistics world,
there's been a lot of blogging about Plus
One is a verb and everyone appreciated that
you put out a Style Guide telling us how to
format. [audience and feedback noise] +1'd.
+1'ing. It's actually a hot topic in the grammar
world right now.
So you give me wonderful fodder for my podcast
and my e-mail newsletter and then your tools
are so useful. I use Google Ngram which you
can search in Google Books to see the frequency
of word usage. And I don't remember which
of my books it's in but I wrote aboutñ excuse
me ñ schadenfreude and I used Google Ngram
to track the rise in the use of the word 'schadenfreude'
over time. It was amazing. It would have been
impossible before Google Ngram released. At
least for someone who isn't in academia would
have been impossible. And also there's something
people talk about. ìJohnny graduated college.î
That's the new way of saying someone graduated.
It's wrong. You should say, 'Johnny graduated
from college.' That's the current standard
American English way of saying it. But what
I didn't know, a hundred or so years ago,
you should have said, 'Johnny was graduated
from college'. So I was able to track the
evolution over time of how 'graduated' was
used as a verb, again using Google Ngram.
It's amazing.
And then finally, Google Books. Again, maybe
someone in academia would have had access
to this but I was able to see scans of the
original style guide that recommended the
serial comma and the original style guide
that had the rule against splitting infinitives.
And for a language geek like me[giggles],
that was so exciting to see the actual scans.
So just big, big thank you. And I hope, I
hope today I can maybe give back a little
bit and maybe help you write better just out
of gratitude.
So I want to convince you a little bit that
word choice, punctuation, and grammar matter.
Because every time I give a radio interview
or a talk, someone says, 'Why should I care?'
Someone in the back whose boss made them come
or something. See, you know what I mean. ëOkay.
So the commas aren't in the right place. Maybe
I didn't capitalize everything properly. What
does it really matter?' There was a study
done that showed that if you look at identical
essays on history or economics, something
that isn't, the students weren't being graded
on their language and the researchers just
changed the mechanics, the punctuation and
the capitalization and things like that. The
students got lower grades on the essays even
though the ideas, the content was essentially
the same. So I think it's reasonable to expect
that in a business setting even if you have
the same ideas presented in almost exactly
the same way in your e-mail messages or your
annual reports or your web pages, that having
errors will affect how people perceive your
ideas. The value of what you're putting forth
on the paper. Now this was a small study but
in the UK, they found-- They surveyed hiring
managers and they found that, they said that
having a spelling or grammar error on a resume
or CV was worse than showing up late to an
interview and worse than swearing in an interview.
[audience laughs lightly] I mean that blew
me away. You're all Google. Maybe you don't
need to worry about finding jobs. Maybe you
have a partner, a parent or a child who's
out in the, out looking for a job and it's
really, really bad to have errors in your
resume and CV. In fact, what always amazes
me and amazes other people, sometimes I hire
people for Quick and Dirty Tips, or an intern
or something and you'd think if you were applying
for a job with Grammar Girl [audience laughter],
you would make sure your resume doesn't have
any errors. And I have seen some atrocious
cover letters, applying for a job with Grammar
Girl. I mean it just seems so obvious to me
that you should get it right. Okay. Maybe
it's not obvious. But I'll tell you, it is
important to [giggles] get your resumes and
your cover letters.
Okay. This is a bit more anecdotal. But I
have literally have had people come up to
me at book signings and say they broke up
with someone because they couldn't stand how
they used language. I'm sure it wasn't the
only problem in their relationship. But someone
said, 'You know, I just couldn't stand any
more that he said "irregardless". [audience
laughter] I mean, really. Someone said this.
And even, even more important is if you're
on, using online dating sites. People send
me all the time ad entries from online dating
sites, descriptions with errors and in them,
'Can you believe this? This is so funny.'
They send them to me because the errors are
somehow funny. They're not just comma errors
or whatever. Some funny word that's wrong.
And so that, that, it can, bad grammar can
keep you from love. If only you knew how to
capitalize properly, you could be as happy
as these people. [giggles] [audience laughter]
And finally, who's seen the movie 'Almost
Famous'. It's one of my favorites. A really
fun movie. This boy, he's supposed to be,
I don't know, somewhere between 14 and 16
and he gets an assignment with Rolling Stone
to cover a band and he goes on the road with
them and writes stories for the Rolling Stone.
It's a great movie. And sort of the underlying
theme is that they don't know how old he is
because he corresponded with them. Over the
phone, he used a fake voice and he sent writing
samples and they were good enough that they
didn't, it didn't occur to him, it didn't
occur to them that he was young. And I was
thinking, while I was watching the movie the
last time, it occurred to me my last intern,
I never talked to her on the phone. We interacted
exclusively by e-mail. And that's super common
these days. I mean how often are you interacting
with people and you have never met them. Maybe
you speak to them on the phone but a lot of
it is just back and forth by e-mail. And so
people are making their opinion about you,
their idea of you in their head, based entirely
on what you are writing. So I hope that I've
convinced you that good, good language skills
matter for life, work, and love.
Iím getting all excited here. [audience laughter]
I hate having so much adrenaline when I speak.
[audience laughter] So let's, so, today I'm
going to go over some of the big questions,
the errors that I see people making over and
over again that people ask me about and then
we'll have time for questions in the end.
So the number one reason that people come
[laughter] [audience laughter], just the number
one reason people come to my website, I'm
embarrassed to tell you. I won't tell you
what percent of the traffic to my website
is 'affect' versus 'effect'. And it's also
the number one, usually the number one and
number two searched for terms in online dictionaries.
So we're gonna spend more than a little, a
little bit significant time on 'affect' versus
'effect'.
So there are exceptions to this rule. [giggles]
And a few years ago I was on the Oprah Winfrey
Show and I talked about this and again I was
a little nervous and I forgot to say there
were exceptions. And I got a nasty e-mail.
Someone wrote, 'Thank you for confusing the
whole world.' [audience laughter] So I'm always
really careful now to say there are exceptions.
But most people don't even know the basic
rule. So if you get this part right, you'll
be right like 85% of the time and that's probably
better than you're doing now. Some of you.
[audience chuckles] I'm sure some of you have
it down. But 'affect' is usually a verb and
'effect' is usually a noun. So Aardvark is
a character in my book. Aardvark and Squiggly
are buddies and they fish together and stuff.
So I, I,the first memory trick I came up with
uses this sentence because it's all A's. So
Aardvark is our friend and it's all A's. ëThe
arrows affected Aardvark.í And 'affected'
is a verb in that sentence. The arrows are
taking an action on Aardvark. They're affecting
him. And you can see that it's a verb by substituting
other verbs and they work in the sentence,
that's a little trick I often use. If I don't
know what kind of word to use, I'll substitute
similar words and see if it makes sense. So
the arrows affected aardvark. The arrows hit
Aardvark. They poked Aardvark. And they annoyed
Aardvark. Those are all verbs. So if you can
remember that sentence, you can compare it
to a sentence you're trying to write and see
if it's kinda like that sentence. And that's
one way to, to choose the right word and remember
that 'affected', the verb, starts with an
'A' because the arrows affected Aardvark.
Now a second memory trick that some people
seem to like better is 'affect' is for verbs
and verbs are actions. And both 'affect' and
'action' start with the letter A. And you
can see these kids, they're, they're affecting
the balls. They're taking action on the balls.
They're making craziness happen to the balls.
So then 'effect' is the noun. And this is
the example sentence with all E's for the
noun. The effect was eye-popping. The effect,
the thing that happened to Aardvark, the noun,
was eye-popping. And you can see that is a
noun by substituting other nouns in the sentence.
So the blood was eye-popping. The holes were
eye-popping. And the sound, the sound Aardvark
made, was eye-popping. So those are example
sentences where one uses 'affect' the verb
and the other one uses 'effect' the noun.
So another trick is that nouns can usually
take an article. So 'the effect was eye-popping'.
'She loved the effect the light had on the
paintings.' And 'the lightning effects were
amazing.' So you can see, in the final one,
there's a word that comes between the article
and the noun. It's modifying 'effects'. It's
telling you what kind of effects they were.
But you can still put an article in front
of 'effect'. When, when what you want is the
noun, you can usually put an article in front
of it. It doesnít work at all with the verb.
So you can't say, 'The arrows the affected
Aardvark' [audience murmurs] 'He was the affected
by the layoffs.' That doesn't make any sense.
It's not even remotely grammatical. So if
you can put an article like 'the' in front
of the word, then the one you want is 'effect'
with an E. And the way I remember it is that
'the' ends with E. And 'effect' starts with
E. So if you have those two E's that can butt
up against each other, then you want the word
that starts with the E. [pause]
And this is the memory trick that actually
works for me. It doesn't work for a lot of
people but I'll share it with you anyway.
[laughs] To some people, some people do say,
'Oh that's my favorite one.' So, I remember
'affect ñ verb; effect ñ noun'. It's a mnemonic
ñ A-V-E-N. And you can make words with A-V-E-N.
So I always think of a raven because you can
spell raven 'R-A-V-E-N'. So if you can think
of that raven in your head and you try to
remember which is the verb and which is the
noun, then you have 'affect - verb; effect-noun'.
So just think of that black raven on the yellow
background and you'll have it forever.
So that was one of my early memory, early
tricks, one of my early tips, one of the first
things I covered. And then I realized, people
starting asking me about 'affective' versus
'effective'. Like it gets harder. So effective
is almost always the word you want. 'She's
a particularly effective leader.' 'We had
an effective meeting. And ëEffective immediately,
we'll have coffee at every meeting.' So really
almost the only time you want to use 'affective'
with an A is when you're talking about a disease.
So, or something in psychology. So I grew
up in Seattle. So seasonal affective disorder,
little children with their, their chins on
window sills looking out at the rain. So seasonal
affective disorder is an example of when you
would use 'affective' with an A. But most
of the time, it's 'effective' with an E that
you want.
So, so that's the end of the 'affect' versus
'effect' section. Hope I've given you some
memory tricks to remember. And then it sort
of leads into the next thing because 'impact',
when people don't know whether to use 'affect',
they often use 'impact' and that bothers probably
20% of the population. Twenty, 80% of the
people have no idea about this but 20% of
the people, when you talk about 'impact' as
a verb, 'The weather impacted fourth quarter
sales', people like lose their minds. They
hate it. So it, 'impact' as a noun is okay.
You can say 'The weather had an impact on
fourth quarter sales'. But as a verb, it's
better to avoid it. And now you know how to
use 'affect'. You can say 'The weather affected
fourth quarter sales.' You don't have to worry
about this. But when you say 'impact', the
sticklers, they think of 'impact' only means
to hit. So this in their mind is an impact;
when they say, when you say, 'The weather
impacted Bob.' They think of like hitting
Bob. Or even worse. Oh I've had people call,
when I was doing radio interviews, and theyíll
say, 'I think of impacted teeth. Or even like
an impacted colon.' [audience laughter] You
do not want people thinking about that when
they're reading your writing. It's just better
to avoid it.
So that's that. Okay. And then, okay. Moving
on. Another common thing that you may or may
not know you do but that bothers a lot of
people is using 'they' or 'their' as a singular
pronoun. So, absolutely, the language is evolving.
So that in 50 years, it won't be an issue.
You can use, people already use 'they' and
'their' as singular pronouns in speech all
the time. I bet even the sticklers and they
just don't even realize they're doing it.
But in print, it still bothers some people
so I tell people to avoid it. Last week, the
Philadelphia Tribune said my, my new book,
"'The Ultimate Writing Guide for Students'
is an essential book for every student regardless
of their age." And I posted this to Twitter
and Facebook and Google Plus and I knew within
20 minutes on every platform, I had a comment
with someone saying, 'Shouldn't it have been
"his or her age"?' So I knew it was gonna
happen. So you know every, the problem is
that 'every student' is a singular noun and
'their' is a plural pronoun. It's easy to
fix. The sticklers would say, 'If you just
wanna make a quick, somewhat awkward fix,
you could say "essential book for every student
regardless of his or her age". Singular, kinda
awkward. If you're doing formal, ñI used
to do science writing, so I would use 'his
or her' because it was sort of a technical
formal type of writing. But, so it's not distracting
in that context but it probably would be for
most of the things you do.
So usually it's really easy to rewrite, to
fix this problem. You could say, 'It's an
essential book for all students'. Make your
noun plural. 'Regardless of their age', then
it works. But sometimes it's hard. And actually
I could not think of a way to make the next
sentence plural. Maybe we could brainstorm
a little bit here. So 'Tell the next caller
that he or she is the hundredth caller and
he or she wins a car.' So we have a person
of unknown sex and we need to tell someone
to tell them something. But 'them' is plural.
You can't use 'them', technically, and I could
not, I sat and stared at the screen for, I
don't know, five, ten minutes trying to think
of a way to make this, to fix this sentence
and I couldn't. Sometimes, sometimes it's
hard. [laughs] Does anyone here, does something
jump to mind? Does anyone see how to make
it plural or fix it?
>>Male Audience Member #1: She.
>>Mignon Fogarty: She, you could. One of my
listeners called that 'whiplash grammar'.
So you could say, 'Tell the next caller that
he is the hundredth caller and she wins a
car.' [laughs] [audience laughter] So sometimes
people will do that. They'll, they'll switch
back and forth between 'he' and 'she' to try
to be gender-balanced and yet still use the
singular pronoun and that is kind of confusing
because you start to wonder, 'Are they talking
about a different person?' [laughs] And all
the, all the style, actually I should address,
that all the current style guides say that
just using 'he' is no longer acceptable. It's
considered sexist language and you shouldn't
use 'he' generically. Yeah?
>>Male Audience Member #2: What about 'they'?
>>Mignon Fogarty: 'They'. You could. Embrace
the plural be on the leading edge. I mean
that's probably what I would do. Yeah?
>>Male Audience Member #3: [inaudible]
>>Mignon Fogarty: You could definitely drop
the second 'he' or 'she'. 'Tell the next caller
that he or she wins , is the hundredth caller
and wins a car.' So it's not so bad because
you get rid of the second awkward 'he or she'
so that would be better too. Yeah.
>>Male Audience Member #4: [inaudible]
>>Mignon Fogarty: 'Tell the next caller that
the caller is the hundredth caller.' [laughs]
[audience laughter] 'Tell the, tell the next
person'
>>Male Audience Member #4: [inaudible]
>>Mignon Fogarty: 'that ñ' Yeah. I mean I
cannot think of another way to do this without
'they' and that is probably what I would do.
I would embrace the 'they' and
>>Male Audience Member #5: [inaudible]
>>Mignon Fogarty: S-SLASH-HE. S-she. And they
all, I mean it's a problem. English doesn't
have a pronoun that does this. It's a, it's
a gap in our language and that's why I think
that 'they' will fill that gap. It's an obvious
need that our language needs. People are already
doing it in speech. It's gonna happen whether
people like it or not. But you should be aware
that you should avoid it whenever you can
because it does really bother people, some
people. Yeah?
>>Female Audience Member #1: So "they" is
OK?
>>Mignon Fogarty: [giggling] 'They' is okay
if you're willing to take a little bit of
heat. So [audience laughter] and I tell people,
I say, 'Be bold. Use "they". Fight for advancement
of our language.' But you have to know that
you will take criticism. I mean like I said,
I posted, obviously my followers are bigger
sticklers than most people. But I posted this
to my profiles and it, it had been commented
on in every single place within 20 minutes.
Someone said, 'They can't use "their". It's
a singular with a plural.' So people, there
are a lot of people out there who notice.
So it's a, I think it's okay to use it but
just know that you should avoid it whenever
you can and when you do use it, it'll, it'll
cause some people to cringe. Yeah.
>>Male Audience Member #6: [inaudible]
>>Mignon Fogarty: Um hmm.
>>Mignon Fogarty: [laughs] [audience laughs]
It's true. No, you're right. Some people,
in, in sort of trying to swing the pendulum
the other way from 'It was he' for so long
for the last hundred years. Now they'll use
'she' all the time except when it's negative
and then they'll think, "Well, I shouldnít
say negative things about a woman so I'll
say 'she' or 'he'". Actually, I find myself
doing that sometimes [chuckles] and if you're
going to use a singular pronoun like 'he'
or 'she', I do think it's a good idea to sort
of try to be democratic about it and switch
back and forth and not always use one or always
use the other. It's funny. You find yourself,
you're writing about something that's been
traditionally male, like a doctor. There's
the classic distinction is, the doctor/nurse.
A man/woman. And every time if I'm writing
about a doctor now and I need to use the singular
pronoun, I'll use 'she' just because it's
sort of the opposite of what has been traditional.
It is a challenge. And another reason I think
'they' is eventually gonna win. It's just
so much less loaded. So ,oh, what? [pause]
That's not supposed to be there. Okay. We're
gonna wing it. So next, we're going to talk
about apostrophes and [pause], can I get to
this? Where is it? I have a movie for you.
Okay. This is one of my, a clip from one of
my favorite videos at YouTube.
[video]
[rap music]
>>Women on video: We like proper English and
we cannot lie. And YouTubers canít deny.
But illiterate kids hittiní on your hits
with ignorant, crass replies. Youíre ashamed
of your fellow man ëcause they really donít
understand. Thereís principles of writing.
ëCause their insults are unexciting. Oh,
baby. You YouTubers haters and slammers.
Just listen to one last thing while we still
have your attention. We got one more thing
to mention.
Sometimes ' your' is possessive but other
times it means you are. Put apostrophes when
you need 'em and otherwise just delete 'em.
So haters, if youíre too confused of which
form of ëtheirí to use, go to Sista Sally's
YouTube page and learn some ways to make your
comments less whack.
[music]
>>Mignon Fogarty: So it's seems so simple.
It's your, their with the apostrophes. And
it's true. When you go to YouTube and you
see the comments, it's always the wrong 'its'
and the wrong 'you're' and 'we're' instead
of 'we areí and ëwere'. So what's the deal?
Why can't, why can't people get this? Let's
see if we can go back. Oh no. [pause] Ahh.
Okay. So, and I will say I am completely guilty
of this too. It's a typo. I have to believe
that most people know the difference between
'you're' ñ Y-O-U- apostrophe R-E and Y-O-U-R.
But you know we think nouns, possessive 's',
you think possessive apostrophe and when you're
typing fast, it's easy to get the wrong one.
And so embarrassing. I know the difference
but in last week's Grammar Girl transcript,
there was an I-T apostrophe S where there
should not have been an apostrophe. And a
'YOUR', a Y-O-U-R when there should have been
a Y-O-U-R-E. These are, I commonly make these
as typos and my editor didn't have time to
edit my script last week. So Grammar Girl
went out with 'it's' and 'your' errors, typos.
So I'm not saying [pause] I can't say you're
stupid if you get it wrong; that would be
saying that Iím stupid. But it's a, itís
a common typo and it's something to watch
for in your writing because it's so easy to
make because you have that association in
your mind of apostrophes with possessives.
So one way that I've been thinking about it
that sort of helps me get it right most of
the time is that I noticed that we use APOSTROPHE-S
to make nouns possessive. But we don't to
make pronouns possessive. I think a lot of
people don't realize that the, that none of
the pronouns use an APOSTROPHE-S to become
possessive. So his, her, their, its and your
ñ those are all possessive pronouns and the
problem is the ones ñ part of the problem
is the ones that end with 's'. So 'its' is
the possessive form of it. Even though if
you were writing about the chair which is
an it, you would use an APOSTROPHE-S. Only
nouns take an APOSTROPHE-S to become possessive.
And there's actually, oh, gosh, my slides
are out of order so I don't know what's next.
Okay. So, but one thing I did want to tell
you about apostrophes and possessives is that
your Spell Checker will mess you up. So children,
it does every time. So children is plural
and to make children possessive, you need
an APOSTROPHE-S. The 'Children's Store', the
'Children's books'. It's an APOSTROPHE-S.
But every single time, spell checker will
mark it wrong. The same with 'men's' and 'women's'
ñ like 'men's clothes', 'women's hats'. It'll,
it takes an APOSTROPHE-S and your Spell Checker
will mark it wrong. So there's just something
to know and it's so funny and people will
write to me and they'll say, 'Well, I'm pretty
sure this is right but Spell Checker keeps
telling me that I'm wrong' and they keep questioning
themselves. Spell Checker is wrong a lot.
So just view it as something that highlights
things you should look at. It's not God. It's
not always right. I'm amazed how many people
will just accept what Spell Checker tells
them. [laughs] It's very dangerous.
So. Boy. Okay. Serial comma. Who knows what
the serial comma is? Everyone? No. Good. Not
everyone. Good. [laughs] So the serial comma
is this comma before the final ëandí in
a list. 'The lions COMMA tigers COMMA and
bears'. Oh my. Itís that comma before the
'and'. Itís called the 'serial comma' because
you use it in a serial, a series like this.
And it's also called the 'Oxford comma' because
it's used by the Oxford University Press which
is one of the biggest presses in the world.
And there was a big kerfuffle a couple weeks
ago. I don't know if anyone heard about it.
But there, so, someone on Twitter, an anonymous
Tweeter called 'Rantee Editor' was at the
Oxford University website and found a style
guide that said not to use the Oxford comma.
On the Oxford University Press Website. And
it, it was hard to tell from the page. It
looked as if it were a university-wide style
sheet. But it was actually for the PR department
when you downloaded the whole .PDF, it was
clear it was just for one department and the
press often use, the press, I should back
up. The serial comma is a style. So a lot
of people will learn either you always use
it or you never use it and they think that
everyone else is wrong. But it's actually
a style choice. So book publishers like Oxford
University Press and the Chicago Manual of
Style, they use the serial comma. But the
Associated Press doesn't. They say to leave
it out unless it causes confusion. So that's
why you'll see it done both ways. So the other
people who do it the way you donít do it
are not wrong. It's just a style choice.
So because it was the Oxford University Press
website and they write for newspapers and
newspapers tend not to use the serial comma
and that was why they had the advice not to
use the serial comma. But everyone freaked
out because if Oxford University didn't use
the Oxford comma anymore, that would be sacrilege.
And they quickly issued a statement and it
was fun, excitement in the grammar world,
kind of like +1'ing [giggles]. [audience laughter]
So, so here's an example, so people will say,
'Well, when would it ever be confusing to
not have the serial comma?' So this is a hypothetical
book dedication: 'To my parents, the Pope,
and Jackie Kennedy.' Now that's really clear
with the commas but if you leave out that
second comma, you get 'To my parents, the
Pope and Jackie Kennedy.' [laughs] [audience
laughter] So it's a made up example but there
are instances where you need a serial comma
to avoid confusion and often it's when the
last things in your list could be paired in
some way.
We'll talk about ëlessí and ëfewerí. This
is a commonly, commonly confused words. So
this is Aardvark again. As I said, he likes
to fish. 'Less' is for things that can't be
counted. And 'fewer' is for things that can
be counted. So water can't be counted. I mean
a glass of water you could say 'We have fewer
glasses of water than we did last week.' [pause]
But water itself in a lake can't be counted
so that you'd say 'we have less water in the
lake'. So things that can't be counted use
'less'. So 'less water'. Things that can be
counted use 'fewer'. So 'I should eat fewer
M & M's.' 'I should leave fewer books on my
desk.' 'I should have brought fewer slides.'
[laughs] [audience laughter] So that, that's
the difference between 'less' and 'fewer'.
And this was funny. I went to the Penn and
Teller show in Las Vegas last year. And Penn
was very proud of his sign. It's a little
hard to read. But one of their posters is
'fewer audience injuries than last year'.
And I guess the marketing people had originally
written it as 'less audience injuries than
last year' and he made them change it to be
grammatically correct. [audience laughter]
And so we took our picture together with the
thumbs up on 'fewer audience injuries' because
the audience injuries are countable. [pause]
Another thing I see people having trouble
with, especially in business, you see this
all the time in business, is improper capitalization.
So capitalizing the name of your award or,
I don't know if an award would be capitalized.
Your tacos aren't crunchier if you capitalize
the word 'taco'. So you capitalize things
that are proper nouns. You capitalize something
because it's the name of something. It's interesting.
A long time ago in English, all the nouns
used to be capitalized. If you look at the
Constitution, all the nouns are capitalized.
It was trendy back when our nation was founded.
But somewhere along the way, and I haven't
figured out why yet. I've been searching Google
Books actually trying to figure out the story
historically. But somewhere along the way,
English changed so that we only capitalize
proper nouns. We only capitalize nouns that
are the name of something. So you capitalize
the name of historic documents like the Constitution
and the Magna Carta because those are documents
that have a name. And you capitalize the names
of bills and acts like the Social Security
Act and the Patriot Act. You capitalize the
name of a department when it's the formal
name of a department. But you don't, excuse
me, you don't say, um, you don't say 'I took
a chemistry class Friday.' You don't capitalize
'chemistry' because it's not the name of anything.
It's just a description of a, a topic. You
capitalize the name of a bridge. You capitalize
Golden Gate Bridge when you're referring to
it but you don't capitalize bridge just when
you use it in a sentence. You say, 'we went
across the bridge'. 'Bridge' is lower case.
But if you say, 'We went across the Golden
Gate Bridge', 'Golden Gate Bridge' is capitalized.
That's a really common, marketing people in
particular just love to capitalize things.
They think it makes it look more important
and it doesn't. It's just wrong. So [laughs].
Hmm. [pause]
Oh here's my run-on sentence slide. So who
thinks a run-on sentence is just a really
long sentence? No one will admit to it. I
know some of you think that ëcause a lot
of people think a run-on sentence is just
a really long sentence. But a run-on sentence
is actually when you join two main clauses
without proper punctuation. And they can be
hard to read. So, they can be short. They
can be really short. So you say, 'I like pizza
Joe went to Domino's.' 'Squiggly cried Aardvark
yelled.' 'Beth went to a yoga class Ben came
along.' So these are all run-on sentences
even though they're really quite short. What
they need is, what they need is a something
to separate the two main clauses. So the one
I can reach [laughs] [audience laughter] 'Beth
went to a yoga class Ben came along' you could
put a period there. You could make it two
sentences. You could put a semi-colon. That's
what semi-colons do. A lot of people don't
like semi-colons anymore and I have no idea
why. But they're very useful. You use them
to join two main clauses when the main clauses
are conceptually related to each other, when
they have something to do with each other.
Ben coming along definitely has to do with
Beth going to yoga class. They're very related
ideas. So it would be completely valid to
use a semi-colon right here to fix that run-on
sentence. You can also use a comma with a
conjunction. You could say, 'Beth went to
a yoga class COMMA and Ben came along.' So
there are lots of ways to fix run-on sentences
but you don't want to leave them like this
because, I don't know if you can tell as you're
reading it but your brain just kind of wants
to pause somewhere. It's like it's leading
you down the wrong path and you think something's
missing when you get to the end. You don't
know why. They're kind of hard to read. And
here's an example. And you can fix them. You
can fix them all with semi-colons and I love
the semi-colon so I probably would.
And there's the semi-colon completely out
of order. [pause] There's another, where is
it? Oh here we go. This is the thing I think
we're running out of time but I wanna finish
with quotation marks because this is another
really common question and there's a reason
you are confused. So when you have a quotation.
People often don't know whether to put the
comma or period inside the closing quotation
mark. And the reason you don't know is because
they do it differently in British English.
And I was looking for examples. I pulled up
the BBC website a couple of days ago while
I was putting together the final slides. And
I, literally I could not figure out what rules
they were following in British English [giggling].
Sometimes they were inside. Sometimes they
were outside. And sometimes it didn't seem
the same to me. I couldn't tell what they
were doing. But in Britain, they follow, they
call it 'logical punctuation'. I could not
determine the logic. But they call it, they
use 'logical', logical quotation marks, logical
punctuation, something like that. So sometimes
they're inside and sometimes they're outside
the closing quotation. In the United States,
the period and the comma always go inside
the closing quotation mark. It's called, it's
actually called, I think it's called 'printer's,
printer's typography' or something like that.
It has to do with in the early printing process,
the period and the comma would get broken
if they were outside the quotation mark. It
was an artifact of printing when they used
real printing presses and little letters.
So this is a US-centric memory trick. So inside
the US, inside the quotation mark. [laugh]
It's easy to remember. Inside; inside. And
it's different, so that's periods and quotation
marks. And it's different for question marks
and exclamation points. So I don't have a
slide but, the question mark, if the thing
inside quotations is the only question, then
the question mark goes inside that closing
quotation mark. If your whole sentence, including
the quotation, the whole thing, if that's
a question, then you put the question outside
the closing quotation mark. So you can think
of it as the question mark stays with whatever
part is the question. And it's the same for
exclamation points. It doesn't come up as
often but the periods and the commas always,
always go inside.
And then, we'll do one more just for fun before
we take questions. So this is one of my favorites.
And another one of my favorite websites is
'The Blog of Unnecessary Quotation Marks'.
Bethany is the author, I forget her last name
but she's great and she has a book out too.
And the whole website is devoted to signs
and photos of people that put words in quotation
marks that shouldn't be. And when you put
a word in quotation, so you can put, I put
words in quotation marks all the time because
when you're talking about a word as a word,
so I'll say, when you're using a word ëwhichí,
it's okay to drop the next clause or something
like that, you put 'which' in quotation marks
or you can italicize or bold it. But you need
to highlight a word some way when you're using
it not for its meaning. But the more common
way to use quotation marks around a word is
to, they're called 'sneer quotes', 'sneer
quotes', or 'scare quotes'. And it means that
you don't mean the thing that's in quotation
marks. Now one of my favorites is a, is a
truck, it says something like 'Bob's ìMeatî'
[audience laughter] and you wonder like what
is Bob actually selling out of that truck.
This one just says 'Fully furnished ìshort
termî lease' and her little funny comment
is 'you can never leave'. [laughs] [audience
laughter] And once you start noticing this,
you'll see it everywhere. People who make
signs love to put things in quotation marks.
Yeah?
>>Male Audience Member #7: Do you have any
idea how that practice started?
>>Mignon Fogarty: I don't know how it started.
I do know, at one of my book signings, two
ladies came up who worked at a sign shop and
they were so apologetic. They said, 'We try
to tell people.' [audience laughter] 'We try
to make them stop. But they're our customers
and we have to do what they want. [giggles]
But we try.' [laughs] They felt so bad. So
that's another, another really common error.
I bet, I bet if you go around Google and you
go into your kitchens and your bathrooms and
anywhere people post handwritten signs, you
will find signs that have things in quotation
marks somehow for emphasis or as if they were
underlined. But don't use quotation marks
in that way because it's funny and a picture
of it might show up on Bethany's blog. So,
those are the main things.
Oh I did want to mention. Oh. Okay. So how
do you settle disputes? This is important
because people spend hours arguing about these
language issues and that's why I appreciate
it so much that you put out the Style Guide
for +1'ing and +1 because it keeps people
from arguing. And that's how you keep from
arguing. You have a style, you have a house
style guide. If you're working in a group,
you decide among yourselves what style you're
gonna follow, what you're gonna do when these
issues come up. So I, I, I would be surprised
if you didn't have an internal style guide
or a recommended style guide for Google. But
if you don't, pick one in your group and decide
what you're gonna follow. And then I wanted
to say a lot of the pictures I used were Creative
Commons, images from Flickr and they're, these
are where you can find them all and itíll
be in my presentation which I believe you'll
have access to. So that's my prepared talk.
I'm out of breath. And I'll be happy to take
questions for as long as you want and they
have books over there, too. I'll sign those.
Yeah.
>>Male Audience Member #9: One thing Iíve
been wondering about. I see people think that
all plurals need apostrophes.
>>Mignon Fogarty: I'm sorry. Could you stand
up? I'm sorry.
>>Male Audience Member #9: People seem to
think that all plurals need apostrophes. And
I have an example, a challenge for you.
>>Mignon Fogarty: Okay.
>>Male Audience Member #9: I was wearing Levis
and an apostrophe might look
>>Mignon Fogarty: Yes.
>>Male Audience Member #9: [inaudible] Is
an apostrophe wrong? Do you skip it when it's
a word like trousers or ?
>>Mignon Fogarty: So the question was about
apostrophes to make things plural. And I think
it was also about, are you wondering how you
make a word that ends with 's' possessive?
>>Male Audience Member #9: No. That one I
know.
>>Mignon Fogarty: That one you know. Okay.
Well, that was one of my missing slides. So
that was something a lot of people don't know
actually is that it's a style choice. So if
you're talking about Levi's fourth quarter
earnings. You could say 'Levis'' with just
an apostrophe or you could say 'Levi's' with
an apostrophe-s. It's a style choice. That
one might not be because of the way it's pronounced.
But Kansas, the Supreme Court Justices actually
argued about whether it should be "Kansas's"
statute with an apostrophe-s or just an apostrophe.
And I forget what they call them, the majority
and the dissenting opinion. They spelled it
differently. [audience laughter] For the same
case. It was a big brouhaha in law journals.
But no, you don't use an apostrophe to make
things plural. It's not common to see someone
use an apostrophe after something like 'Levis'
to make it plural. Levis would be, I think
that is sort of like fish in that the plural
and the singular would be the same. You would
say, 'I have 20', you would say, 'I have 20
pairs of Levis at home.'
>>Male Audience Member #10: [inaudible] twenties
in my pocket.
>>Mignon Fogarty: Right. And that's when it's
much more common for people to use apostrophes
like after an abbreviation, CD's. We had 50
CD's in the closet. It used to be, it's kind
of, it's one of those things that's evolving.
It used to be more common, commonly acceptable
to use an apostrophe to make something like
that plural. The New York Times was the last
holdout. So the New York Times used an apostrophe
to make acronyms, like that, initialisms,
to make them plural until just two or three
years ago. And people would write to me every
week to tell me the New York Times was doing
it wrong but it's a style, it was a style
choice. Now that the New York Times has stopped
doing it, every other major style guide says
not to use apostrophes to make things like
that plural. So now I say don't do it. It's
wrong. But it's, it's something that has changed
over time. But how would you make Levis plural?
What's an example where you wouldn't use pairs?
When would you use say, 'I have 50 Levis.'
You wouldn't just say 'I have 50 Levis'.
>>Male Audience Member #9: I think CD is actually
a better example. I find myself wondering
should I say C-D-S?
>>Mignon Fogarty: Yeah. It's C-D-s with no
apostrophe. Even when, even with the abbrev-,Oh
I can't remember. I, someone asked me about
OS, OSs. Operating systems. And I want, I'm
pretty sure, I think it's O-S-E-S to make
something like that plural. But if it doesn't
end with an S, just add an S. And even if
it's, so RBIs, Runs Brought In, itís still
RBIs. You put the S on the end even though
it's actually 'runs'. That's plural if you
were to spell it out. Someone over here had
a question.
>>Male Audience Member #11: I'm just wondering
what you think about camel case.
>>Mignon Fogarty: Camel case. I covered that
a while ago and it's in one of my books. I
have a cartoon about it. So if, if it's a
company name, then you should write it that
way. You should use it, I should tell you.
Camel case is when you have an upper case
letter in the middle of a word. So PowerPoint.
The P is capitalized.
>>Male Audience Member #12: McMahon?
>>Mignon Fogarty: Hmm?
>>Mignon Fogarty: McMahon as for a name. I
guess that would be camel case. It comes up
so much more often with the name of companies
or the band OutKast. They capitalize the K.
They use a K. I mean what do you expect? [giggling]
[audience laughter] Really, we're gonna hold
them to high standards when they spell OutKast
with a K? [laughs] I, I think it's, it's,
it's kind of annoying. It's better to avoid
it. It comes from, it comes from programming
because often you can't put spaces in variable
names and file names and things like that.
So it started with programmers using capitals
in the middle of everything to differentiate
word from word. And oh gosh. There was someone.
I know what it was. It was someone who had
a company named NetEase wrote in and said
that he thinks the drive to use camel case
so often in company names because it's hard
to find a domain name and so you have to string
lots of words together and then if you don't
capitalize the first part of the next word,
it can look weird. Because he said his parents
always tease him that his company is KneeTease.
Like your knee. Because if you didn't capitalize
the E in NetEase, it looked like KneeTease.
So there's a drive. There are a lot of logical,
practical reasons to have camel case and if
a company writes their name that way, then
you should write it that way. I, yeah. I mean.
Just try to avoid it when it's unnecessary.
Yeah.
>>Male Audience Member #13: I have sort of
a Google question about Latin versus English.
Is it okay to say ëForumsí?
>>Mignon Fogarty: Forums? Oh. Is it fora?
>>Male Audience Member #13: Yeah.
>.Mignon Fogarty: Yeah.
>>Male Audience Member #13: It seems like
some of that stuff is disappearing.
>>Mignon Fogarty: It is.
>>Male Audience Member #13: We donít need
to know as much classic grammar as before.
>>Mignon Fogarty: Yeah. The one I was really
surprised about is agenda. So agenda is plural
and the singular if you want to say, you would
say 'What's this meeting's agendum?' [laughs]
[audience laughter] If you wanted to use classical
language. So a lot of that is going away and
a lot of it, in some instances there are two
ways to say it. So 'index', I think the Wall
Street uses 'indexes' and scientists still
tend to use 'indices'. So, in some instances,
both the Americanized version and the classical
version co-exist. And in other instances,
they, the, the more modern version has taken
over like with 'agendas'. I would say 'Forums'.
[laughs] Yeah?
>>Female Audience Member #2: I have a personal
pet peeve about try and do something. Is that,
it's so common. I see it written all the time.
Is that becoming acceptable?
>>Mignon Fogarty: It's actually one of my
pet peeves too. [laughs] So people will say,
'I'm going to try and call you tomorrow.'
Well that means you're gonna do two things.
You're gonna try and you're gonna call. The
proper way to say it is 'I will try to call
you tomorrow.' The 'to' is a preposition and
the function of prepositions is often to connect
words together. To connect ideas together.
And so the proper phrase is 'I will try to
call you tomorrow.' But you're right, the
'try and' is becoming pervasive. I don't know
if it's a losing battle or not. I, I don't
intend to give up on it yet. There are some
battles I have given up on. 'Momentarily'
is one. So 'momentarily' means for a moment.
So if you say, 'The plane will land in Phoenix
momentarily', that means you've got a touch
and go. [laughs] [audience laughter] Traditionally
but it's become so common for 'momentarily'
to mean 'in a moment' that it's just a lost
cause. We're never gonna win that battle so
I give up. But I haven't given up on 'try
to' yet. Do you have a question or are you
leaving?
>>Male Audience Member #14: A question.
>>Mignon Fogarty: Okay. [laughs]
>>Audience Member: When is it appropriate
to use underlines in printed text versus italics?
>>Mignon Fogarty: Hmm. Well it depends on,
when should you use underlines versus italics?
Well it kind of depends on what style guide
you follow. So the Modern Language Association,
which is usually the style guide used for
writing research papers, tends to favor underlining
more than other style guides. But since the
rise of the net, underline means a link. Underlining
has really fallen out of favor. So I prefer
not use underlining whenever I can avoid it.
Just because people thinks it's clickable
then. Our brains have changed how we think
about underlining. But typically, an underline
would be, ñI don't even, I think it's from
the title of a work. Like in the MLA, you
underline the title of a book maybe. I'm not
super familiar with their style.
>>Male Audience Member #14: Oh. Okay.
>>Male Audience Member #15: What if you have
a font that doesnít have italics?
>>Mignon Fogarty: If you're in a font that
doesn't have italics, usually if you have
italics, you have underlining. The bigger
problem is on sites like Twitter and Facebook.
I haven't checked Google Plus yet to see if
they do this. But you can't make italics or
underlining on, on these social networking
sites. And so then you end up putting things
in quotes but it bothers me because, if I'm
putting the title of a book, titles of books
don't go in quotes in any style. But itís
the only way to really highlight them when
you could put underlines next to each of them
or asterisks. But asterisks really mean bold.
It's frustrating and in the publishing industry,
they write book titles in all caps. It's sort
of an inside the industry thing. It's not
any acceptable style guide but it's all throughout
publishing. So then I started to maybe trying,
like a couple times I've written my book titles
on Twitter and Facebook and Google Plus all
caps. But then it just looks like you're screaming
and that bothers me too and I just want italics
but I don't think it's gonna happen. Oh, you
have to come up. I have formally said that
my preferred style is all caps because it
conserves space. You're not, you've got 140
characters for example. You don't want to
use two of them on quotation marks but I still
don't like it. I'm not resolved to it. Yeah.
>>Female Audience Member #3: I have a question.
I'm pretty loud too. Let's say you're using
a nickname. You're putting that in quotes,
right?
>>Mignon Fogarty: Um hmm.
>>Female Audience Member #3: Say there's a
good salesperson. They call her 'The Closer'
or something. So in that case does the period
still go inside the quote at the end of the
sentence?
>>Mignon Fogarty: Yeah. The period always
goes inside the quotation marks. And that
actually brings up an interesting point. So
you capitalize nicknames but you don't capitalize
terms of endearment. And this is something
people are often confused about. So if you
say 'Our salesperson, Bunny, had a great year.',
you capitalize Bunny if that's what everyone
calls her. But if you said, if youíre, if
you're coming up to say your boyfriend and
you say, 'Hey, sweetie.' Unless, unless you
always call him 'sweetie' and that's what
you think of as his name, 'sweetie' is lower
case because it's just a term of endearment.
And sometimes it's hard to find that, figure
out which is which but you capitalize nicknames
and you don't capitalize terms of endearment.
Yeah?
>>Male Audience Member #16: Commas before
ëbutí when itís not used as a conjunction
and when itís not used to separate independent
clauses so it can that indicate a difference?
>>Mignon Fogarty: Um hmm. So usually you don't
put a comma before 'but'. So the commas are
super-tricky. They're like 25 different comma
roles and one of the sort of exceptions is
that you can always use a comma when you need
it to avoid confusion and you can use it to
show contrast. So you could say, 'Squiggly
hid behind the tree COMMA but felt brave'
because those are in such stark contrast,
the comma helps draw attention to the contrast.
And again, it's one of those style calls.
Like how much contrast do you need before
you can use a comma. But, but you can in instances
where you're showing a contrast. Yes?
>>Male Audience Member #17: How about 'that'
versus 'which'?
>>Mignon Fogarty: 'That' versus 'which'. Yeah.
Another common one. So I have a memory trick
for that too. So the memory trick is that
with apologies to Hermione Granger, you can
always throw out the ëwhichesí and no harm
will be done. So if you have a, so 'which'
is for non-restrictive clauses and 'that'
is for restrictive clauses. So what that means
is it's better with an example. So you could
say, 'I like diamonds COMMA which are expensive.'
So because diamonds are always expensive,
at least in my world, the 'which are expensive'
is a non-essential clause. It's sort of restating
the obvious. You don't really need it. So
if you could, it doesn't really change the
meaning of the sentence if you get rid of
that 'which' clause. So if you can throw out
the 'whiches' and it doesn't change the meaning,
then 'which' is the right choice. Now I could
say, 'Dogs that bark make me crazy.' So 'that
bark' is an essential part of that sentence.
It changes the kind of dogs we're talking
about. I love dogs. It's just dogs that bark
that make me crazy. So, so you can't, you
can't throw it out. And so you can't throw
out the 'whiches' so you need a 'that' instead.
So there's some exceptions actually to that
rule but that's the basic rule. Come on. [laughs]
Someone stump me. No? Well, thank you again
for having me and, and for making all the
cool Google tools that I use. I hope you learned
something and I have a free Podcast at iTunes
and a free e-mail newsletter at my website
which is quickanddirtytips dot com. And I'll
stick around and answer your questions and
sign books and stuff. Whatever you want. So
thank you.
[applause]